you should speak a bit so that you keep
the volume down until the introduction
is done
okay you can control it i mean that's
not right
okay so let's start
so now we'll have
let's start now we'll have a talk by tim
moldin who will talk about fine-tuned
and faithful a natural abuse of
terminology in causal modeling so the
floor is yours okay thanks um
good so
i
i think i can get through this in in
pretty decent time uh let me do the
prologue
which contains two theses
um
one is that language is the medium by
which we communicate formulate clear
propositions
and propose compelling and convincing
arguments
thesis two
language is the medium by which we
engage in miscommunication and gender
confusion and get misled by bad
arguments
um and obviously they're both true
and it means we have to be awfully
careful if we want to understand each
other and understand what's going on
uh
in exactly what various pieces of
terminology mean
so
here's the tentative plan this is this
this has been
adapted to what what what's happened so
let me just go over the plan so i'm just
gonna
begin
going over a list of
of terminology that's problematic okay
you ought to be careful about it i'm not
saying don't ever use it but sure think
a bit
about what it means when you use it and
try and think a bit about what it means
when somebody else uses it because they
might mean something different
uh some not so problematic terminology
usually when you drill down on any of
these things far enough you run into
some issues
but but at least at first
first pass this seems okay
then
i want to do this just because it was
clear not everybody has seen this
argument and it's just beautiful if you
want to go to sleep go to sleep and then
wake up for this part and then go back
to sleep okay because this is really
cool if you've never seen this it's just
tremendously cool
uh
the the this ghz argument
uh and then i want to talk about
how certain phenomena are explained
causally the causal structure the
explanation in a particular way of
understanding
quantum theory and and uh
you get a very clean account
it's a surprising one and it's one that
i think some people are not familiar
with
and so it's useful
and then finally uh what the title this
is what i thought all i would be talking
about is some particular terminology
that comes up in the causal modern
literature
and that has been
brought over in people worrying about
quantum theory the idea being okay we
have these issues trying to understand
quantum theory maybe if i go to this
other literature and apply it see how it
applies i can make some progress right
but i think actually we've made anti
progress by doing that for reasons i'll
give you okay
so here's some problematic terminology
some of this has been used in this
in this meeting
sometimes people say something is
classical as opposed to quantum they're
classical
classical causes and quantum causes or
classical probabilities and quantum
probabilities classical logic and
quantum logic okay
uh
here's a word which you might not think
is problematic but i'll explain why it
is the word theory
uh here's another one hidden variables
which
well i i don't need to do this now i'm
going to come to these things this is
just to warn you the terms contextual
and non-contextual which actually have
been used i'll show you
and the terms
realist or realism which sometimes come
up in discussions and this is very
general if you're in this area you
better get clear about this stuff let me
just talk about this one i'll talk about
this one in the most detail
i get i give you a theory
and then i say okay you tell me right
i'm going to give you the theory now you
tell me whether it's a classical theory
or quantum theory right
what do you do
what do you look at
um
okay we've had an explicit suggestion
that was made we've had actually a
couple of them that were made
early on on the first day one is that
well ask yourself can the states in this
theory the physical states be cloned
right or broadcast duplicated whatever
you like
um and on the quantum side there's an
actual formal argument here
the no cloning theorem
which runs from the unitarity of the
hamiltonian evolution
to saying there just can't be a
a unitary evolution that takes as an
input some state and and gives it an
output two copies of that same statement
right that's clean if all you've got is
unitary evolution
um
but on the classical side if you say but
gee in any classical theory you can
clone states you can copy states i give
you a state in principle you ought to be
able to copy that state
oh yeah
i've never seen a theorem of that i
don't even know how you begin to to to
to prove such a fear right
so classically i hand you a box of gas
okay and it's got 10 to the 20 third
different particles in some position
and velocity distribution
and you're telling me well in principle
there's some i don't know what machine i
can build that'll build me and you know
copies of that in exactly that same
state
i don't know how you do it i don't know
how you go about trying to prove such a
theorem i don't even know what it means
right so the idea that somehow well
classically everything is cloneable not
in any practical way certainly
no theorem of the sword you wouldn't
even know where to begin
so i'd be worried about this if
clonability is the issue it's not clear
that classical theory is classical
uh there's another suggestion made
classical states are in some way
controllable same issue here
right because of course if everything
were in principle perfectly controllable
then they'd be cloneable right then
gee of course in principle and i specify
to you a state of a gas right in a box
with
10 to the 23rd particles and i tell you
exactly where i want each particle and
exactly what velocity i want it and i
say here go build me that
okay if you can do that then you can
clone it because you can just build it
again
but who says you can do that
what
what print by what principle could i
even begin to prove a theorem that you
can do it because now you need a whole
theory of what you can do
where does that come from
this is a starting point
you start from a theory so it's a
theoretical problem
i
i'm just look i'm raising questions here
i don't want to get caught on this stuff
but i'm just saying if you want to claim
you can prove this stop a minute and
think
okay i and i can get
i'm going to talk about a theory in a
second so then i'll come back
i can give you a theory but still not
answer all the questions you would need
to prove with theories
uh
so here's a data point this is just
sociology i'm going to talk a lot about
this theory called bohmian mechanics
pilot wave theory and just it's true
that many people who don't like the
theory
uh
run down people who like the theory by
saying oh you're all conservatives and
you just can't get with the quantum
program and you're stuck with classical
ways of thinking and
this is a classical theory right so some
people will say foaming mechanics is a
classical theory
but sure it gives all the same
predictions as quantum mechanics so you
might think it's a quantum theory
what do you mean
now personally i think i i just don't
think there's there's any payoff to this
right i mean i could sit here you could
make different proposals what makes
something classical who cares
some piece of terminology right deal
with the theories in front of you
well deal with the theories what's a
theory now here i've got a big complaint
i've made this forever some of you will
have heard this
uh people talk about theories they talk
about classical theories and quantum
theories they talk in particular about a
thing quantum theory i use this term in
a very specific way
for me to have a physical theory means
you've provided me within epsilon okay
there might be some fuzziness but pretty
well you've provided me with two things
you've specified an ontology in a
dynamics
what does that mean
i specify the ontology by telling you
what the theory postulates to exist
to be real
to be in the world
okay as opposed to being epistemic or
some function of somebody's beliefs or
whatever
and the dynamics once you've given me
the ontology the dynamics then specifies
how the ontology behaves i usually do
that by giving you some dynamical
equations
okay to me that's what a theory is
and
by that
standard if you open a usual textbook
that has the title quantum theory it
doesn't give you with you
okay because it's just not clear
what's actually being physically
postulated
you use a wave function does it
represent something physically we're
real you use some collapsed postulates
is that something that's really going on
in the world is that nearly epistemic
are you just updating on information
standard textbook won't tell you
just won't
uh
now so
i can give you all that
and give you a proper theory and still
not have answered questions that were
relevant to controllability because that
requires them talking about well who's
doing the controller i mean this was all
in a way this was maxwell's point with
his demon he said look
we big fat human beings with big stubby
fingers can only do such and such
and we can't get can't convert
thermal energy
in a box at equilibrium into useful into
useful mechanical energy but this
quick-fingered little guy could do it
so
to make the distinction of what can and
can't be done that's one that connects
up to thermodynamics you actually have
to talk about human beings what they can
do
and that can change right that's not
that's not part of the theory as i
stated it right because that's part of a
hypothesis about human beings god knows
i wouldn't want to have to do that okay
the term hidden variables comes up a lot
john bell
says in a nice place that the the the
things called hidden variables in
quantum theory says it's a piece of
historical silliness
that that term is used he was 100 right
uh
you might think it's just the same thing
as latent variables and causal modeling
it really isn't
so that's just warning for people in the
causal model in literature when you see
hidden variables in the quantum context
don't think oh that's just latent
variables that i'm used to
um
in particular i'm going to talk about
bohmian mechanics
and there
that there are
pieces of the ontology
which are actual particle positions
which are called hidden variables
okay but man they are not hidden
if they were hidden in the normal sense
of hidden you couldn't see anything in
fact
what you basically see when you open
your eyes and look around at the world
is the positions of things
and in this theory it's the positions of
things that happen to be made up of
particles and the positions and shapes
and so on of large objects made up of
small particles is a function of the
positions of those small particles
i mean as bell said what's really hidden
in bohmian mechanics is the quantum
state that's kind of hidden not that you
can't get at it entirely but it's not
easy to get at
so just be careful when you see that
again my suggestion avoid the term
altogether we don't need it
this distinction contextual
non-contextual that comes up in
discussions of quantum theory two
uh
and i think this is also kind of
terrible terminology very misleading
why
really what it means is that a theory is
contextual means that the outcome of an
experiment can depend on how the
experiment is done
thank you okay yes
now it's a little more specific than
that
there's a way in which
certain experimental setups are
associated with permission operators in
quantum theory and it can turn out that
physically different setups get excite
get to get associated with the same
permission operator
and in a contextual theory
what's really going on in that
experiment may depend upon which of
those setups you're using
okay even though they're associated with
the same permission operator
but ultimately you're just saying what
you know the way an experiment works
depends on how it's actually done the
physical the physical way it's
implemented
okay
that is people who think oh there's
something weird about this theory it's
contextual no
incredible if every theory if theories
were not contextual in the sense of you
want to understand and experiment take
into account the physics of the
experimental situation
the terms realistic realism come up a
lot
i've saved the worst for last
um
it comes up terribly in this people say
this stuff bell's theorem refutes vocal
realism
but they say gosh i love locality i you
know you will prize locality out of my
cold dead fingers
so okay i'll give up the realism part
and keep the locality part
uh i like to say this this is the
position nothing actually exists but
thank god it's local
this is just this makes no sense
whatever
technically there is a good meaning to
the term scientific realism that comes
up in the epistemological literature in
philosophy it means a very specific
thing i don't even have to go into it
because it has to do with epistemology
not with metaphase not with ontology not
with physics it has to do with what
certain evidence entitles you to
reasonably believe
but that's not a physical question
and the term realism shouldn't be
showing up in these discussions at all
good okay so that's some bad terminology
to avoid here's some good pretty good
terminology local
so in a in a relativistic setting and
for all practical purposes in a
non-relativistic setting
you can assign a sharp meaning given to
the modifier local
so this one's good
in particular locally
causal theory is one where what
all of the causes of an event
sit in or on the past light cone of the
event and in a relativistic theory
that's all well defined so if you're
going to have causal arrows in a locally
causal theory they gotta run
they can't as it were go faster than
light
now you don't have light cones in a
classical theory but for all intents and
purposes you can talk about things going
faster than light even in a classical
setting all right so this is pretty good
and you've got causal locality and you
can talk about signal locality
which is similar but where you say
a theory is signal local
uh if if you've got what would normally
be considered a setup that you can use
to transmit arbitrarily chosen messages
that the transmitter in order for the
thing to work the transmitter has to lie
again in or on the pass light cone of
the of the of the receiver where
there are transmission events where you
press the button and reception events
where somebody sees a blip on a screen
so a local you know local signaling
that's pretty well defined so that's
good
now
uh what's the basic idea for locality
why is that good well
why should you think a theory ought to
be locally causal
because you think causes have to precede
their effects
right
and
uh when you're sending messages the
person pushing the button that event has
to precede the reception
of the signal
and uh
and that's why in in the standard causal
modeling literature you insist on an
acyclic right that's what the a is all
about you've got an acyclic graph
because you things can't go around in
causal circles
at the level of specific individual
causation
because that would require going around
in temporal circles
and you know absent weird stuff about
time travel and blah blah blah that
can't happen
right that's why you want dags now of
course if you're talking about causation
at a more generic level you could have
feedback loops that have circles in them
but you know you think
yeah but that's that's only because i'm
uh agglomerating things that are at a at
a generic level i'm corresponding in a
certain way if i get down to the
specific individual events you never get
circles
good now in relativity if you just start
with that idea that causes have to
precede their events in relativity
when events are space like separated
that is when they lie outside each
other's light cones they have no
definite causal order temporal order so
if you demand that causes precede their
events
you can't have causal connections
between space like separated events
because they don't have a temporal order
right
uh
so this puts a nice constraint on the
kinds of causal models
you're allowed
in a locally causal theory
yes
now
here notice the idea here that you have
a restriction on causal arrows that's
given by this but by the
relativistic constraint
this is of absolutely zero interest to
uh people doing economics and people
doing epidemio you're never gonna have
to worry about that right you are never
ever ever
dealing with separate events that are at
space like separation
okay
all the events you deal with giving
somebody a shot whether they get sick
and blah blah blah right you know you
change their education and then what
happens to their income all of that has
a perfectly clear temporal order
even taking relativity into account
so this idea of this sense of a locally
causal theory will really be of no
interest now i suppose one could have
other reasons
for thinking theoretically there ought
not to be causal relations between some
nodes in a graph right and you could
sort of impose that and then get similar
results but they won't be the ones that
that came up for belle
right they won't be the ones we're going
to be talking about those come up
because of relativistic considerations
okay now we get to bell's theorem
so what does bell actually prove
he shows that if you if you do some
experiments at space like separation
which means i don't have a definite
temporal order in relativity
there are certain just observable
results from those
experiments that cannot be
replicated predicted or explained by any
locally causal physics right that's the
content of the theorem
now we could again there's always
epsilonics and there's a statistical
independence assumption that goes in but
that's what there really tells us
and
then we can conclude something from it
because we actually do these experiments
and we find that they violate
the the the uh inequality that he proves
and we
we draw the right conclusion actual real
physical physics in the actual real
physical world is not locally causal
which is really quite a surprise
i mean you really ought to be
you really ought to be surprised at that
now
the exact definition of bell locality
we could go into some
epic cycles about but you should just go
and read uh there's a late paper
called la nouvelle cuisine by bell where
he gives his most kind of explicit
account of exactly what he means by
locality and there's some stuff about
markov consideration so on but
not really relevant
uh
and
in this talk really signaling doesn't
come up right if you if you prove that
the theory can't be
locally causal you might then worry okay
i've got non-local causation can i then
use it for
creating non-local or super luminal
signaling
okay and that's an interesting question
but it's not
anything that bell's worried about
right bell isn't talking about signals
okay so then we get this
this dag that's always used for the chsh
stuff
and you see what's going on that the
state preparation of a pair of particles
lies to the past of some experiment bob
does
bob himself is way over here making some
experimental decisions alice is way over
here making some experimental decisions
and this and this are space-like
separated from this and this so if it's
a causally local theory i can't put any
arrows going from here to here or there
to there
yeah so i'm restricted to a graph like
that
and then you ask a question all right
what kind of statistics can this
structure recover
uh
and that's the usual bell theorem the
usual bell theorem in the sense the one
he actually proved to notice this is a
bipartite experiment where i'm dealing
with a pair of particles
in a particular quantum state
now what apparently may not be so
familiar is that much later
greenberger horn and xylem were fiddling
around with this stuff and they came up
with this really beautiful example ghc
example
which is different from bells
it's more complicated in a way because
it involves not a pair of labs but a
triple so now we've got bob
alice bob and charlie but their labs are
arbitrarily separated so that the
decisions they make about what to do in
their labs and the outcomes of their
experiments that they record in their
labs all happen mutually at space like
separation from the others
okay so we can
say in a locally causal theory again we
can't have arrows running across this
thing
what's nice about this example is that
the relevant predictions are all
deterministic right they're not in in
the bell case
the relevant predictions are in part
they're partly deterministic and they're
partly
statistical
so to test it you've got to run the
experiment many times or anyway to get
anything you would think of as an actual
empirical outcome
uh that could viola that that that
checks this you've got to run the
experiment many times because you're
checking statistics against statistical
predictions
but in this case they're not they're all
surefire 100 all the time every run
predictions that's what's so beautiful
about this tells you that the
probability part isn't really playing a
role when merman first i've read about
this stuff from david merman and he said
merman had worried a lot about bell's
ceremony he said i always thought
somehow it was important to the theorem
that it'd be fundamentally statistical
and he said and then i read this i was
wrong right
okay
so that's why i want to go through this
now now you can wake up now the
important part okay so here's
schematically the situation i have a
source
that's going to create a triple of
particles in a certain
well-defined quantum state it's going to
send the three particles out in three
different directions i've got alice bob
and charlie that sit in their labs and i
can separate their labs 100 billion
billion billion billion miles apart
doesn't matter according to the theory
according to the predictions of the
theory
and
alice bob and charlie are making spin
measurements so they're using these you
know we always show by these stern
gerlock magnets
which create an inhomogeneous magnetic
field
a little pointy part
we can think of as the up direction
and the deal with these magnets is that
you can orient them
in space in any direction you like
and
part of the
maybe surprising
predictions of quantum mechanics is that
when you do that
and you send one of these particles
through here
it will either be deflected a certain
amount up that is toward the pointy part
like this would be an up result
or the same amount
away from the pointy part that would be
a down result right and we can we you
can set that in any direction you like
here this is a down result here this is
an up result we only care for the
purposes of this argument that alice bob
and charlie have the option of sitting
at either in the
x direction or the z direction
okay
where here the x direction is
horizontal and the z direction is
vertical so this would be a situation
where
these two abs are set in the z direction
and this one's set in the x direction
yeah and whenever you do this you'll
either get up or down
good
now we've got a pair of predictions of
quantum theory for this particular ghz
state
and they're very simple to understand
now we can imagine that that alice bob
and charlie are flipping coins or doing
whatever the heck they want to decide
randomly
on any given run whether they're going
to set it this way or that way right
and so you would think well if they're
really doing it randomly with 50
probability there are eight possible
global configurations and each one will
come up about one eighth of the time
we only care about the predictions for
four of those cases right
the other four we just don't need makes
predictions quantum theory makes
predictions we don't care about them
just delete that data it doesn't matter
look at just all of the results for
these four configurations if they all
happen to choose the x direction right
so if they're all horizontal
then with certainty
the theory doesn't tell you exactly how
many up and down outcomes you'll get
among the three of them but it does say
it'll certainly
uh be odd
right a hundred percent of the time
always always always odd one sometimes
one time sometimes three
okay
that's the other the other nice thing
about this example is all the math you
have to know is even a not right if you
understand even an odd you're golden
here
if in if on the other hand
two of the detectors are set in the z
direction and one is set in the x
direction which can obviously happen at
any of three different distinct physical
ways
then again you get a 100 sure fire
prediction that you'll get an even
number of up outcomes could be zero
could be two
but you'll never get one or three
are the predictions that's it
what do we conclude from this
well
the nice thing about these surefire
predictions you'll notice if i know
that there have to be an odd in a
certain circumstance i say ah
they all set
to x
so there's certainly an odd number of up
outcomes
and if i happen to know any pair of them
i know what the other one has to be
right there's a
a a certain inference
from alice's result and bob's result to
what charlie's result had to be
this is like the
epr correlations that einstein padolsky
and rosen used in their original 1935
paper that involve perfect correlations
right the nice thing about perfect
correlations is what the nice thing
about perfect correlations is
in a local theory it rules out
indeterminism
right it tells you if you've got a local
physics and these two experiments are
happening far apart let's say it's space
like separation
then the results in each of the labs has
to be predetermined
why because i mean let's just take the
simple case we're familiar with in the
spin in the cingulate state if they both
measure spin in the same direction
you'll always get one up and the other
down sometimes you'll get it this way
and half the time you'll get it this way
and half the time you'll get it this way
but it always they'll always be
oppositely oriented so if i know one i
know what the other is
and if anything really
fundamentally probabilistic or chancy
happened on this side the question is
how in the world does the other side
know what to do
right i mean bell puts this very nicely
in bertelman socks and the nature of
reality if you want to read but that
it's a very simple argument right
there's no problem
getting a result like half the time you
get this and half the time you get that
okay
um
in a deterministic theory it's trivial
right you just predetermine
the results and half the time you
predetermine them this way and half the
time you predetermine them that way and
you never predetermine like this like
this
and so there's nothing in that that
phenomenology that suggests non-locality
that was the epr point
but man if there was something really
really fundamentally chancy going on if
god were playing dice you'd be in
trouble that's why
and i'll just say this einstein wasn't
worried about
the the indeterminism of quantum
mechanics and he says that it said in
letters
he's worried about the non-locality
and there's a beautiful thing he says
that god plays dice and uses telepathic
methods as is proposed by you know the
current understanding of quantum
mechanics it's the telepathic methods
bit that he doesn't like
right the non-locality
okay
so
first conclusion is because we've got
these perfect odd even things going on
if you want to recover this data in a
local theory it has to be a
deterministic theory you have to
predetermine at the source
exactly what each of the particles will
do under each of the two possible
experimental settings they might run
into because they don't know what
they're going to run into depends on how
alice and bob's coins come out or
whatever
good
so nothing can happen by chance that's
our first conclusion it has to be
predetermined
now we have this this is again due to
merman it's really beautiful nice little
graph here
we've got
this
circle represents
if in in in
lab one alice's lab her thing is set in
the x direction this represents if her
thing is set in the z direction okay so
these are the the circles represent
experimental situations
x the one lab set to x the two f set to
x the three lab set to x
and you'll notice that in this diagram
these four lines correspond to the four
global experimental situations we care
about the dotted one
is the one where they're all set to x
and the other three solid lines are the
three possible situations where
two are set to z and the other one's set
to x
okay
so now we ask a very clear question we
just proved that in a locally causal
theory we have to predetermine for each
of we have to write u or d in each of
these circles
okay predetermine the outcomes
and we want to predetermine them so that
we'll get the right result no matter
which of those four
experimental situations happens to show
up
right let's try so we know we need an
odd number of views along the dotted row
there are obviously many ways to do this
let's try this let's just make those all
u's so stick three u's in there so if
they happen
to all
check in the x direction i'm okay
let me just kind of randomly stick in a
d here in the middle just because i'm
tired of u
and now let me try and finish it out
remember i need an even number of views
along the solid lines so u d i'm forced
to a u here
and now i'm screwed
right
because
i need a u to make this even and i can't
put a u to make that and
you might say well maybe you just made a
bad guess somewhere but there's this
lovely argument that merman gives he
says look you think you can do that this
is a mathematical question can you put
us and d's in this graph that satisfy
simultaneously all four constraints if
you think you can
imagine i've got little tokens with you
or d written on them okay pick up those
three and throw them in a hat i now have
an odd number of views in the hat
pick up these three and throw them in a
hat even these three even these three
even okay so i threw an odd even even
even i now have an odd number of views
in the hat
but
i picked up every token twice because
every single of these lies at the
intersection of exactly two lines
there's ain't no way i'm going to have
an odd number of views in the hat
period end of story that's a
mathematical proof no locally causal
theory can produce
this kind of data but as a matter of
fact the world does
for anybody interested this is the
relevant ghc state written out
in the x basis and you can notice
i only have terms where there's an odd
number of x ups
i have all four terms they're they're
equally likely because i have halves
here these negative signs are really
important if you want to know what
happens in the other circumstances just
rewrite it in another in the relevant
basis say the zzzx basis and you'll see
that you'll get evens
okay
how can that happen
well i want to talk about how it
actually does happen according to a
particular theory real theory real
theory that specifies how the world
works namely bohmian mechanics but i'm
going to take a simpler case i'm going
to go back to the cingulate state you'll
remember the cingut state is a
entangled state of a pair of particles
such that if i check for the spins in
the same direction any direction i like
but in the same direction i'll always
get
opposite results one up and one down
okay
if you have an actual theory you can go
into the guts of the thing and say all
right physically what happens according
to this theory what's the causal
structure
and
um
just the fact
that i always get opposite results that
could be explained locally
but it turns out in this theory it isn't
even though you don't need it
in this theory even just to get this
simple singlet state behavior for
always measuring in the same direction
in fact it's a non-local theory it has
non-local causation so i just want to
explain that
what's bohmian mechanics okay so the
this thing or sometimes called the pilot
wave theory sometimes it's called the
boreal bone theory
the on i say you have to give me an
ontology and a dynamics the ontology is
there's a quantum state which is
represented by a wave function
everything you might ever call quantum
theory has that and it's in the ontology
of this theory it is particles
just plain old regular particles little
tiny objects
okay they might be point-like you want
to make them a little fat go ahead i
don't care they're well located and they
follow continuous paths through space
time okay that's the ontology chairs and
tables and cats and people are made out
of particles in certain chair and table
and cat
shaped configurations and they move
around because the particles move around
in just the way democritus would have
told us you explain the macroscopic
world by reference to the way the
microscopic continuum constituents are
behaving
so that's the ontology what's the
dynamics well for the quantum state it's
just the schrodinger usual schrodinger
revolution that guy that every quantum
theory uses at least some of the time
where
this is the
hamiltonian operator i take it everybody
you know and we have a
time derivative that's telling us this
is dynamics how things behave in time
that's a linear equation
okay
what about the particles well the
particles also
are governed by a very simple equation
it's called the guidance equation this
is a nice way to write it you'll notice
that psi shows up in the guidance
equation it means that where the
particles go depends on what the wave
function is
okay that's the sense in which the wave
function is piloting or guiding the
particles because their dynamics is a
function whereas you don't have any you
know back here there's no mention of the
particles right
okay so that's the guidance equation
this is
how the position of the k particle is
changing with time
and you just take a kind of k-k
gradient
here you might wonder why i've put a psi
star on the top and bottom here that's
to deal with spin won't go in to take
the imaginary part of it but anyway you
see that equation good that's the theory
i just gave you the theory the
non-relativistic theory
uh suppose we
prepare a state in an eigenstate of
x
x up but i measured in the z direction
we know the quantum prediction is 50 up
50 down
since a deterministic theory there has
to be something that determines whether
individual particle goes up or down it's
not the wave function because the wave
function i do this many times and after
a while i get 50 of about 50 percent go
up and 50 go down the wave function's
always the same it's got to be the
particle position and that's what it
does it determines where it goes and in
fact in an extremely simple way
here's my garlock magnet here's the
central axis of symmetry
if the particle
initially starts out above the axis
that guidance equation will deflect it
up
and if it starts out below that guidance
equation will deflect it down
what about the cingulate state
and here if you don't know this this
david albert explains this very nicely
in his book quantum mechanics and
experience
what about the cingulate state where we
know
one of the particles will go up and the
other will go down how is that
determined in this theory
um
now you might think
well i guess if it's if we're the same
it means either they're prepared this
way or prepared that way right with one
up and one down relative to the axis but
no you can start with them both up you
can start with them both down that's
okay
good all right um but what will happen
what happens is the first one to get to
its detector does what i just said if
it's in the upper part it goes up it's
in the lower part it goes down
and the second one this is in the
non-relativistic theory so we don't have
any problems about time order
is then again you're just following out
the guidance equation goes the opposite
way
okay
and so the causal structure is non-local
that is where bob's particle goes can
depend on when
not just what but when alice makes her
measurement
you might be able to say in this theory
oh bob's particle went down but if alice
had just delayed her measurement it
would have gone up clear causal
connection produced by counter factual
dependents
and so we get a
in each run we either get this causal
diagram
or we get that causal diagram depending
upon whether alice or bob's
does their experiment before the other
with respect to time okay but it's
non-local in the sense that the error is
going across
and therefore
there's nothing in the data that's going
to be restricted by bell or chsh because
you have those arrows
and there's nothing the causal structure
is perfectly clear you understand what's
going on causally there's no
non-classicality there is
non-locality
um now the last point i want to make and
i'll just make it and once
this is what the whole thing was going
to be about
in the causal modeling literature
this kind of structure has a feature
that's called quote fine-tuning or
unfaithfulness or unnaturalness
okay it has a feature that formerly it
has a feature that goes by those names
and that sounds like an objection
right a reason not to like this theory
why well
if a fine-tuned theory just generally
you think is methodologically suspect if
we think about the word fine tune
and you know fate unfaithfulness is
actually grounds for divorce so that
looks pretty bad
um and unnaturalness my god you know
we're doing
natural philosophy you better not have
an unnatural theory so you might say
well that's the argument is look we can
analyze this theory and they turn out to
be fine-tuned and blah blah blah blah so
these are bad things okay
now
here's the actual example finely tuned
bells no fine-tuning faithfulness okay
all this terminology i just said came up
no classical causal model could explain
honestly
without fine-tuning there and this was
also from this very conference no
faithful classical causal model blah
blah blah no faithful classical causal
model bad bad bad bone bad bone bad
unfaithful okay fine tuned bad bad bad
now all i want to say and this is really
the end of it this is a rhetorical trick
i want to discredit quantum field theory
so i introduce a piece of technical
terminology and i get to define it
because like humpty dumpty i can define
my terms
a theory is totally unacceptable by
definition by my stipulation if it uses
an infinite dimensional hilbert's space
well by definition quantum field theory
is totally unacceptable
you can't complain there
but we shouldn't take seriously any
theory that's totally unacceptable now
of course there was a trick there which
is that i removed the quotation marks
right i went from the technical meaning
that i defined to the everyday meaning
which is pretty bad but that's just a
joke
nobody take that serious that's all
that's going on here why do i say that's
going on here is this a fine-tuned
theory look i gave you the theory
um let me just remind you this is the
theory
you think that's fine-tuned
show me what's fine-tuned in it
right we had an example before where you
only get a result if some row is set to
a half
and then you might say that's fine tuned
because row could be any of these values
and it all you only get this result when
it's set to happen there ain't nothing
to fine-tune in this thing
so in the normal sense of fine-tuned it
is not fine-tuned
it if it comes out being quote
unfaithful in some sense too bad
why should i care
perfectly acceptable theory clear sharp
comprehensible
and so
uh
if you're if your criterion for being
fine-tuned says that this theory is
fine-tuned the problem's not with the
theory it's with your criteria
use of terminology
okay and i would argue similarly for
unfaithful and unnatural where those
things come up also sometimes people
complain it's contextual so what
okay so
thanks
so
well we are already over time but we
have questions yeah of course
um thanks very much tim uh i've got a
comment and a question i just wanted to
make a quick comment and that is and
when you were referring to the fact that
people didn't understand the gh said i
just wanted to make it clear that it
wasn't miriam who was the speaker at the
time who didn't understand what she said
she um when you're referring to that
talk because a lot of people jumped in
um
yeah anything else i've just said
yeah
but i just wanted to make that clear in
case anyone misinterpreted what went on
in that exchange during miriam's talk
um anyway but my question is uh so with
bohmian mechanics which i don't really
know a lot about that interpretation but
my understanding from what you've said
is that there's no
testable implications of that theory
that go beyond quantum mechanics so any
time there's no
implications of quantum mechanics that
go beyond that theory and it has the
advantage of actually being a theory
okay so that's so so um i do understand
that correctly then
so um typically in my physics actually
let me just make it it's not clear okay
i mean it would when you get into fine
details you ask questions which nobody
asks like suppose i do an a a an
iran-off-bomb experiment but i change
the flux in the in flight
okay
so i can do arrival time experiments
it's not even clear how you make
predictions about that in quantum theory
because there's no time operator
so when you say does it do they make all
the same predictions that that can be a
much more subtle question and you can't
even ask it until you actually have a
well-defined theory on the table
yeah okay so i guess um to finish off my
question the question was that
uh
you know you're talking your your
preference for it is from what i
understand is the fact that you think
you know well that it gives you an
ontology and it gives you a set of
dynamical equations and that that's
something you would like of a physical
theory
what about the fact that um physical
theories also are often preferred
because of their usefulness so physical
theories will tend to stand to test the
you know will stand the test of time
when people use them and and when
scientists use them in communication and
in solving problems and to my knowledge
no one uses by mean mechanics no working
physicists use birming mechanics to
solve problems so i'm just wondering if
that poses anything um i'll tell you
this working chemists do
um chemists chemists who actually have
to have to deal with much more
complicated systems than physicists do
because don't even get up beyond high
helium usually you know to what they can
do
chemists have to worry a lot about uh
a lot about electron orbitals and how
electrons behave in in for large macro
molecules and they actually use bohmian
mechanics they use those equations when
they're doing numerical simulations to
figure out how to how how to put fine
grids where the action's going to happen
that's going to be physically relevant
for the way this thing comes out
so yeah people use it furthermore
the entire point
the effectiveness of the quantum
formalism as it's usually used the
quantum predictive formulism as it's
usually used is explained by bohmian
mechanics
so of course i can use something that's
effective for making predictions not
understand why it works
i don't i don't really care about i only
care about predictions insofar as they
give me ways to to think that theories
are worth taking seriously
not because i care about predictions per
se
engineers might not care they just care
about the outcomes they just want their
chips to work okay fine i'm not an
engineer
i'm a physicist i get to be a
philosopher
i just want to know how the world is
so i think there is also a question
online so the online people can ask
directly i guess
i don't know did you hear julia rubino's
talk um
on
experiments
beautiful talk uh experiments in which
the time
order there was this in the process of
things happening it wasn't what she
meant
yes i heard the talk but that i was
wondering how much elonian mechanics
deal with no no what she said was
extremely misleading she had alice and
bob but each of alice and bob could make
their experiments at two different times
so to do this properly that is to go
down not to the generic level but the
specific level you needed not an a box
and a b box you needed an a early box an
a late box a b early box a b late box
and the the the uh
super position was first to alice and
then so alice early bob late or
alice or bob early
alice late but that wasn't any
indeterminacy about the time order of it
of those four
four events
so that talk the way it was presented
was extremely misleading
saying that this had something to do
with indeterminate time order it has
nothing to do with indeterminate
timeline
uh is
bohmian mechanics good with that
duplication of
the different analysis and the different
bobs i mean
that's just true the talk is pretty
clear about about this duplication any
any theory can deal with about alice is
sitting in her lab and she something's
going to come in at 12 and she can do
something to it
or
something's going to come in at 12 30
and she can either do the same or
something else to that
that's all that was going on and the
same for bob
there had to be enough time for the
actual single particle to get from alice
to bob right i mean there was literally
a physical particle being sent from
alice to bob that has to be time-like
separated
there's nothing space like going on in
that
it's literally do i first send it to
alice and then alice shoots it over to
bob or do i first send it to bob and
then bob shoots it over to alice
and this was
there was there was nothing about
indefinite time order in that section
but those two possibilities
show interference terms is the issue
well
sure but that's just normal that's like
two-split interference
yeah but it's just normal interference
stuff of course you get that out of this
so
it's fine i i propose that we pass to
the next question of uh eric
thanks um so yeah i wanted to ask a
question about your definition of local
causality maybe could you go back to
your slide where you defined that sure
um maybe why are you you you do that
maybe just a comment also
causes lie in the past of their effects
so all the causal arrows in a
relativistic setting the causal arrows
are always between time-like or possibly
like related events right that's all
right okay
right but it's not at all because the
definition of local cause either we can
think of that as being the conjunction
of relativistic culturality plus
rahmat's principle of cause which says
that um
treatments are correlated if there is a
common cause
in the past like well there's a common
cause but in the if you're similarized
to viscosity in the compass like coin
but importantly such that conditioned on
the common cause the correlations
factorize or another way of putting that
is that a full specification of the
causes of an event fully specify
the probabilities for that event to
occur or if it deterministic determines
which event is going to occur and you
omitted that from the definition so but
that's the important part this is this
is the obvious definition it's the one
i'm using you want to define it some
other way to find it some other way but
this is the obvious thing to say the
important thing is that if you don't
include the other thing you cannot
produce bell's theorem because you can
reject of course you can i just i just
did i mean
i proved for ghc you can't get the ghc
predictions out of a locally causal
theory
the the hidden assumption and i thought
assumption the hidden assumption is that
the causes of the event fully specify
the probabilities for the event to occur
therefore it's not correlated
then i made no such a supplement
[Music]
that there is a central assumption
because that assumption that he wrote
there on the graph is maintained in
quantum causal models that's precisely
the point of consequent response is to
maintain the idea that the causes of the
event are in the past like current but
the complete specification the causes
are not fully specified probabilities
are event in such a way that events
which have space like separate become
irrelevant for predictions of other
events so it's the second part the
quantitative part of rhinobar springs
which is violating quantum possible
models but not the thing that you wrote
on the board so there is a constructive
proof
of reproducing bell's theorem while
maintaining the thing that you have
involved and everything else that you
assumed therefore you cannot have proof
that no there's not a constructive proof
relative to the definition look you can
define quantum causes to be whatever you
want
okay and maybe you can prove it will
satisfy the notion of local causality
that you have on the board
let me just say something in a locally
causal theory if i have fundamentally
probabilistic events and you can have a
you can have a stochastic locally causal
theory
the condition now is that the joint
probability for space like separated
probabilistic events
is is just the product okay so there's
no correlation no not by what you wrote
yes
that's the definition
so i'm i'm sorry i i guess that this has
to be like written and
again answered in more time
so
i propose that we stop here right
and uh well it's the end of the morning
session so good lunch